Olá você quer desinchar a sua próstata
ou prevenir problemas como a hiperplasia
prostática benigna a próstata crescida
então imagine consumir dois alimentos
fáceis de achar e que Ten o poder de
proteger você contra uma das doenças
mais comuns que afetam os homens a
partir dos 40 anos aqui é o Dr Alan
Machado Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos
e hoje eu vou compartilhar com vocês
dicas de dois alimentos incríveis que
são estudados e comprovadamente ajuda a
proteger e até tratar homens com esse
inchaço na próstata primeiramente é
importante esclarecer que o aumento
Benigno da próstata não tem relação com
câncer embora ambas as condições possam
coexistir normalmente o crescimento
Benigno do tecido prostático não se
transforma diretamente em câncer
portanto se você foi diagnosticado com
hiperplasia prostática benigna Fique
tranquilo agora vamos entender
rapidamente sobre esse crescimento da
próstata a causa exata do aumento da
próstata ainda é desconhecido mas
sabemos que fatores hormonais
desempenham um papel importante conforme
os homens envelhecem há uma queda
natural da testosterona acompanhada por
um aumento da dihidrotestosterona
chamado DHT e também aumento estradiol
esses hormônios contribuem pro
crescimento prostático Além disso ocorre
uma redução na apoptose que a morte
celular programada que ocorre dentro da
próstata contribuindo ainda mais para
aumento desse órgão então esses fatores
juntos ajudam a explicar o crescimento
prostático mas a ciência ainda está
investigando detalhes para entender como
é que funciona isso a fundo quando o
homem começa a ter esse problema de
crescimento da próstata próstata grande
o que acontece é que o inchaço do órgão
comprime a uretra que passa por dentro
dela isso provoca dificuldades para
urinar e como consequência diversos
sintomas muito incômodos você pode notar
que o seu jato de urina fica mais fracco
que o fluxo de urina é interrompido vai
saindo aos pouquinhos Além disso você
pode sentir dificuldade de esvaziar
completamente a bexiga causando aquela
sensação de que ainda Precisa urinar
mais isso faz com que você tenha que ir
ao banheiro muito mais vezes
especialmente à noite interrompendo o
seu precioso sono
outro sintoma comum é o gotejamento de
urina pós urinar que acontece na cueca
em casos mais graves pode até ter perda
de urina no caminho até o banheiro que é
uma condição conhecida como
incontinência urinária de urgência
pessoal em situações extremas pode
ocorrer uma retenção urinária aguda onde
o canal urinário fica completamente
bloqueado necessitando de ser submetido
a um procedimento com sonda para aliviar
para desobstruir E permitir a saída de
urina Esses são os principais problemas
que surgem quando a próstata está
inchada Mas vamos para uma das soluções
e quais são esses alimentos milagrosos
para a saúde prostática existem vários
nutrientes importantes mas aqui eu quero
falar de dois alimentos que são até
fáceis de encontrar e consumir durante a
semana você pode consumi-los todos os
dias ou pelo menos três vezes na semana
e acho que é uma boa dica porque são
alimentos fantásticos para prevenir e
tratar a hipoplasia prostática benigna
eu sempre indico esses alimentos
específicos para os pacientes que estão
sendo tratados por mim então vamos
começar falando primeiro do licopeno que
é um carotenoide encontrado na melancia
na cenoura e na toranja mas a melhor
fonte desse carotenoide é o tomate o que
eu indico pros homens Nessa idade é o
consumo de tomate no mínimo três vezes
por semana e é melhor ainda que seja um
molho de tomate se você conseguir
cultivar o seu próprio tomate ou comprar
tomates orgânicos melhor ainda mas se
isso não for possível você também pode
consumir molhos de tomate se for um
molho industrializado preste muita
atenção aos ingredientes não adianta
nada comprar um molho de tomate que tem
açúcar ou outros conservantes prefira
aqueles que tenham apenas tomate como
ingrediente principal mesmo que sejam
industrializados a principal dica é
utilizar o tomate na forma de molho
porque o licopeno vai ficar muito mais
concentrado se toma também mais
biodisponível quando aquecido Isso
significa que quando você aquece o
tomate uma grande parte do licopeno é
efetivamente utilizada pelo corpo fazer
seu próprio molho de tomate em casa
aquecendo será muito mais benéfico e
permitirá uma melhor absorção dos
benefícios do
licopeno Além disso O licopeno é um
composto solúvel em gordura então é
importante utilizar alguma forma de
gordura ao consumir tomates ou molho de
tomate a combinação ideal é com azeite
de oliva que faz uma dupla fantástica
para ajudar a saúde da sua próstata você
pode preparar um belo molho de tomate
quebrar alguns ovos dentro e adicionar
azeite de oliva e suas ervas favoritas
por cima isso não só melhor absorção do
licopeno mas também deixa o prato
delicioso Então essas são as duas dicas
principais aquecer o tomate para
aumentar a biodisponibilidade e
concentração do licopeno e usar uma
fonte de gordura com azeite de oliva
para melhorar a absorção desse elemento
nosso segundo alimento são as incríveis
sementes de abóbora essa sementes são
repletas de componentes benéficos e eu
recomendo muito o consumo delas além do
do uso de óleo de semente de abóbora que
também é muito interessante mas falando
do consumo diário de alimentos as
sementes de abóbora são especialmente
valiosas elas são uma excelente fonte de
magnésio mas principalmente de zinco que
é um mineral essencial pra saúde da
próstata o zinco também é conhecido por
melhorar a qualidade do esperma e ser
benéfico para a fertilidade masculina
Aumenta também os nível de testosterona
além do zinco os antioxidantes presentes
nessas sementes também protegem a
próstata e podem reduzir o risco e
melhorar os sintomas da próstata
aumentada um estudo de 2021 mostrou que
o óleo de semente de abóbora ajudou a
reduzir os sintomas do hpb e Melhorou a
qualidade de vida dos participantes e
isso totalmente sem efeitos colaterais
ao comprar prefira aquelas sementes com
casca você pode consumi-las com a casca
se não tiver problemas com fibras ou
desconforto intestinal ou descascá-los
para consumir as pepitas outra opção é
comprar abóboras utilizar a polpa que é
deliciosa e nutritiva e aproveitar as
sementes torrando as em casa sugiro
consumir sementes de abóbora no mínimo
três vezes por semana uma a três
colheres de sopa de sementes de abóbora
são suficientes aqui vai uma dica
interessante para cuidar da saúde da sua
próstata prepare um um prato com molho
de tomate cozinhe alguns ovos nesse
molho e por cima adicione sementes de
abóbora aquelas pepitas esverdeadas
tempere tudo com azeite de oliva sal
integral cúrcuma e ervas frescas Esse
prato é delicioso e muito bom pra sua
saúde prostática compartil os vídeos bem
a de além pode mudar também no
canal Alé
Espero que tenha gostado desse vídeo eu
vou deixar na descrição o link para um
vídeo completo sobre o uso da Semente de
abóbora onde eu explico mais detalhes
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera